puder lippenstift lidschatten
kosmetik ist ein milliardengeschäft in
dem beauty influenza in wieda jana eine
immer größere rolle spielen
starten mit dieser palette hier dies
limitiert also seid schnell wenn ihr sie
noch haben möchtet ich weiß nicht wie
lange sie noch gibt sie testen und
empfehlen produkte pushen damit den
umsatz aber weiß diana auch für welche
inhaltsstoffe sie da wirkt das kann man
natürlich nicht leisten sich jetzt
wirklich durch dieses ganze
inhaltsstoff bewusst durchzulesen und
durchzublicken vor allem ich bin ja kein
professor sondern auch nur ein normaler
verbraucher der eben die produkte seien
freundinnen oder eben der community
weiter empfiehlt und ja ich denke schon
dass die firmen da ein auge drauf haben
sollten und die firma muss im endeffekt
dafür stehen und das vertreten können
mieter zum beispiel ist ein wichtiger
grundstoff der in vielen kosmetika
steckt hauptfunktion der glitzereffekt
ein mineral das hauptsächlich in china
den usa oder in indien vorkommt hier im
nordosten indiens in jharkhand liegt der
sogenannte glimmer gürtel etwa 30
prozent des micra das nach europa kommt
stammt von hier zum beispiel für
autolacke und eben auch für die
kosmetikindustrie
[Musik]
mit einfachstem werkzeug haben die
arbeiter löcher in den boden ist zu zehn
meter tief ohne sicherung immer wieder
brechen ihnen ein menschen werden
verschüttet auch kinder bis zu 22.000
kinder arbeiten hier für glamour und
glitzer in den gefährlichen nie kam
ihnen die jüngsten sind gerade einmal
sechs oder sieben jahre alt in der
prallen sonne schuften sie bei bis zu 45
grad
ich komme jeden tag hierher um acht uhr
morgens ich seine etwa 10 bis 20
kilometer bis zum abend
ein knochenjob und das für nur zwei euro
am tag die kinder hier kennen nichts
anderes
auch dieser junge nach eigenen angaben
15 jahre alt ist praktisch in den minen
aufgewachsen diese arbeit machen dann
würde ich verhungern
darum müssen wir unser leben riskieren
und hier arbeiten
natürlich haben wir angst aber es hilft
ja nichts
die kinderarbeit ist kaum zu
kontrollieren
armut ist ein ganz großer faktor die
menschen hier haben einfach nichts die
meisten erwachsenen können selbst nicht
lesen und schreiben viele wussten noch
gar nicht was ihnen bildung groß bringen
soll darum haben sie die kinder einfach
mitgenommen auch die ganz kleinen
sie konnten sie ja nicht alleine zu
hause lassen dazu kommt dass die kinder
leicht in die minen hineinkommen
abschied von terre des hommes versucht
seit jahren die kinder aus den minen
herauszuholen ihnen eine perspektive zu
geben
[Musik]
noch vor wenigen monaten haben viele
dieser kinder in den mika minen
gearbeitet jetzt dürfen sie zur schule
gehen
[Musik]
die viele von euch waren sonst in den
minen
wie ist es euch das früher begonnen
ich hätte acht schnittwunden
ich habe mich ja gesammelt die mienen
waren sehr weit weg weit hinten im wald
eine stunde von hier
von der kinderarbeit in den minen
erfährt man in europa oft gar nicht
weiter verarbeitet wird das mica meist
von frauen in handarbeit
viele zwischenhändler sorgen dafür dass
alles korrekt aussieht dass mika wird
immer weiter verkauft teils mit
gefälschten zertifikaten dass am ende
nachzuweisen ist schwer
zurück in deutschland auf der beauty
messe in düsseldorf mangelt es nicht an
glitter und glamour auch influenza
indiana ist hier zum allerersten mal
sieht sie bilder aus indischen mit
kaminen bilder die zeigen unter welchen
bedingungen rohstoffe für kosmetik
abgebaut werden also ich liebe wirklich
glauben wichtig dass sie gerade in ganz
ganz anderen beigeschmack
so was möchte ich natürlich auch gar
keinen fall unterstützen
und
dass das paket nicht tatsächlich wusste
das nicht dass das so abgebaut wird wie
ihr geht es wohl vielen nur die
wenigsten beschäftigen sich mit den
inhaltsstoffen ihrer kosmetik dajana
will in zukunft genauer hinschauen bevor
sie über produkte berichtet